Like all of Guillermo del Toro's films, "Pinocchio"
is complex, deeply contemplative and far more
than it seems.
Here's what this master of the macabre has
to say about the classic tale.
Spoilers ahead!
The historical setting of "Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio" immediately lets you know that
the film will have a more serious focus than
past versions of the story.
The beginning of the movie takes place during
World War I, and as warplanes are making their
way back to base, they drop bombs just to
lighten their load.
One of those bombs lands on Geppetto's church
and kills his son Carlo.
From there the film's antiwar message becomes
even more explicit.
By the time Geppetto creates Pinocchio, many
years have passed.
World War I has come to a close, but Benito
Mussolini has come to power in Italy and fascists
dominate almost every aspect of daily life
in Geppetto's town and the surrounding areas.
Geppetto, like many of the other Italian citizens,
does his best to play along with what the
fascists want to avoid any violence at their
hands.
Pinocchio isn't so agreeable.
He's a rambunctious young boy who likes to
do things his way.
Just by being himself, Pinocchio shines a
light on just how wrong the fascist belief
system is.
The primary antagonists of the film, the carnival
owner Count Volpe and the government representative
Podestà, are both fascists who want to crush
Pinocchio's spirit for the glory of the fatherland.
It's Pinocchio's individualist streak, unlimited
optimism, and empathy for other people that
ultimately allow him to prevail over his foes.
In all its different forms, Pinocchio's story
is partly a coming-of-age tale about a boy
learning how to be good and take responsibility
for his actions.
In most versions of the tale, like Disney's
classic rendition from the 1940s, learning
to be good is synonymous with learning to
obey the people who are supposed to be in charge.
Pinocchio usually learns that if he follows
what the adults in his life tell him, then
things will generally work out for him.
In Guillermo del Toro's version of the story,
however, most of the adults in Pinocchio's
life are fascists, espousing terrible rules
and life philosophies that only serve to devalue
other people.
"Look at my boy Candlewick."
"Yes, yes, yes…"
"A model fascist youth: proud, brave, virile!"
Geppetto might not truly be a fascist himself,
but even Pinocchio's father can't serve as
a great example for the young boy because
he's willing to go along with what the fascists want.
Unlike past versions of the story, Pinocchio
in this film doesn't need to learn how to obey.
His disobedience is what sets him apart from
the other people in his life, and it's what
makes him a hero.
For del Toro, Pinocchio's disobedience in
the film is the whole point.
Speaking with the Washington Post, he said,
"Disobedience now is more urgent than ever."
Pinocchio's real journey through the movie
is learning how to use that disobedience to
help others, like when he breaks Death's rules
and hourglass to save Geppetto's life.
Pinocchio doesn't learn how to be obedient
in the film, but he does learn how to be good.
At the beginning of the movie, Pinocchio breaks
rules to get what he wants.
He leaves Geppetto's house to follow his father
to church.
He skips out on going to school because he
wants to drink hot chocolate at the carnival.
By the end of the movie, he's breaking rules
to save lives.
What changed?
Pinocchio's journey away from home takes him
through plenty of hardships, but two moments,
in particular, demonstrate how Pinocchio's
experiences cause him to change his attitude
in life.
First, Pinocchio sees Count Volpe beating
and berating Spazzatura.
He immediately steps in to defend the monkey,
and when that doesn't work, the two of them
conspire to sabotage the Count's performance
for Mussolini.
Later Pinocchio is taken to a training camp
for fascist soldiers.
There he comes to understand that his old
bully Candlewick was just being cruel because
that's what his father Podestà taught him
to do.
Pinocchio and Candlewick become friends and
rebel against Podestà's rules.
Throughout the film, Pinocchio suffers, but
he also witnesses others suffering of others
at the hands of the people in charge.
All of that convinces him to change the way
he goes about disobeying and transforms him
into a true hero.
Pinocchio isn't the only one who changes over
the course of the film.
He also transforms the people who are closest
to him.
Geppetto goes through the biggest change,
but Sebastian's transformation has the biggest
effect on the film's plot.
After Geppetto loses his son Carlo, all his
joy for life vanishes.
His work slows down to the point that even
when his town's church gets rebuilt, he never
finishes his new crucifix carving because
he spends the majority of his time drinking.
The war ends in 1918, Benito Mussolini rises
to power in Italy in 1922, and Geppetto remains lost.
The Wood Sprite gives Pinocchio life so he
can bring joy back into Geppetto's life.
The two of them get off to a rough start,
but by the end of the movie, Geppetto has
found love and motivation all over again.
He's willing to risk being eaten by a monstrous
sea creature just to see Pinocchio again.
Sebastian begins as a self-centered writer
whose main interest in Pinocchio is that he
already has a home set up inside the wood
of the puppet's body.
The Wood Sprite promises Sebastian one wish
if he teaches Pinocchio to be good, but things
work out in the opposite direction.
Sebastian tries giving Pinocchio a lesson
or two, but by spending time with the boy,
Sebastian himself learns to be more selfless.
He uses his wish, not for fame but to bring
Pinocchio back to life.
"Well, gosh darn it.
I wish him back to life!"
There's another character in the movie who
goes through a drastic change thanks to Pinocchio,
and his transformation mirrors Pinocchio's
growth.
Candlewick is the son of Podestà, a war-obsessed
fascist government official who lives in Pinocchio's town.
When the boys first meet, Candlewick takes
a cue from his father and acts like a bully
toward Pinocchio, going so far that he convinces
Pinocchio to stick his wooden legs in a fire.
All that changes in the film's final act.
Podestà ships Candlewick off to a special
military training camp for young boys, and
eventually Pinoccio finds himself there as
well.
Podestà is obsessed with the idea of using
Pinocchio as an immortal soldier, but neither
of the children is genuinely interested in
fighting a war.
At the training camp, Candlewick confesses
to Pinocchio that he just wants to make his
father proud of him, and Pinocchio comforts
him by telling him all fathers love their
sons, but fathers are still people and don't
always behave the way they should.
In a training exercise, Pinocchio and Candlewick
come to a tie, and Podestà orders his son
to shoot his new friend.
Candlewick refuses, finally telling his father
that he doesn't need his approval.
He and Pinocchio rebel against the camp's
leadership just as bombs begin to fall.
Guillermo del Toro spends some time musing
on mortality in "Pinocchio."
Shortly after Count Volpe's carnival is introduced,
the Count and Geppetto get into a fight over
Pinocchio that ends when the puppet gets hit
by Podestà's car.
To the humans, it appears as though Pinocchio
died, but he wakes up in a version of the
afterlife populated by skeletal rabbits and
a sphinx-like creature called Death who says
that the Wood Sprite is her sister.
Death tells Pinocchio that the Wood Sprite
brought him to life because she doesn't care
about following rules.
Then Death explains the rules of Pinocchio's
new almost-afterlife.
Every time he dies, he'll arrive in her world
and have to wait for larger and larger hourglasses
to run through their sand before he gets sent
back to the world of the living.
Near the end of the movie, Pinocchio dies
while Geppetto is drowning, and he breaks
the hourglass to get back more quickly, even
though it means he'll become truly mortal.
Pinocchio dies one final time in his efforts
to save Geppetto, but thanks to Sebastian's
wish and the Wood Sprite's magic, he gets
resurrected and has the chance to live out
his life with his family.
Death may have warned Pinocchio that by breaking
the hourglass he'd gain mortality and become
"a real boy," but she also knew that her sister
would intervene.
Death's warning was more about testing Pinocchio's
character than it was about limiting his lifespan.
When Sebastian enters the film, he begins
narrating different events.
He explains that when he first met Pinocchio,
he was a writer working on a book about his
life, and he tells the story of how he first
got involved with Geppetto, his puppet, and
the Wood Sprite.
At the end of the film, Sebastian talks about
Pinocchio's long life with Geppetto and Spazzatura,
who both eventually die as Pinocchio goes
on agelessly.
In some instances of Sebastian's narration,
the camera shows him writing as he's speaking,
which make it all the more surprising when
Sebastian begins to narrate over his own death.
Just after seeing that Sebastian, like the
others, died, we catch up with him in the
afterlife, playing cards with the skeletal
rabbits who work for Death.
The transition makes for a quick twist.
It reveals that all this time, Sebastian wasn't
narrating from some grand book that he wrote
about his adventures.
He gave up that dream to save Pinocchio's
life.
Instead, Sebastian has been telling his life
story to the disinterested rabbits over a
few hands of poker.
The darkly humorous turn in the story is emblematic
of what sets Guillermo del Toro's "Pinocchio"
apart from other takes on the story.
Sadly, Pinocchio outlives Geppetto, Spazzatura,
and Sebastian.
He's not a human being, and he never ages,
even as the people around him do.
The tragic part of his existence is something
that Death warns him about when he first visits
her domain.
Initially, Pinocchio is thrilled at the prospect
of being immortal, but Death tells him that
immortality is more of a curse than a blessing.
"Life can bring suffering, and eternal life
can bring eternal suffering."
When Pinocchio decides to break Death's hourglass
so he has enough time to save Geppetto from
drowning in the sea, she tells him that not
following her rules will make him mortal again.
Does the Wood Sprite's final spell, fulfilling
Sebastian's wish, undo Pinocchio's newfound mortality?
Yes and no.
Pinocchio is still on his "last life" like
Death told him he would be.
The Wood Sprite gives him one more chance
at that life, but she doesn't make Pinocchio
truly immortal again the way he was before
breaking the hourglass.
That said, Pinocchio is still a wooden puppet,
so he isn't likely to die from old age anytime soon.
At the end of the film, Sebastian says that
he imagines Pinocchio didn't live forever,
but his friend still gets to have an extraordinarily
long life compared to normal humans.
In the film, Death claims that Pinocchio's
"realness" is tied to his mortality.
She says that human life is unique because
it is short, but even though Pinocchio gets
to live for a very long time, he's still gone
through the transformation of becoming a real
boy by the end of the film.
In more traditional versions of Pinocchio's
story, like Disney's classic film, his journey
ends when he gets magically transformed into
a physical human being.
That was never going to be the case in Guillermo
del Toro's version.
Speaking with Vanity Fair del Toro revealed,
Pinocchio's transformation from an inhuman
puppet to a real boy was a slow process that
began when he first met Geppetto at the beginning
of the film.
In a way, every interaction he had with the
people he met further pushed him toward humanity,
but it was the moment that Pinocchio smashed
Death's hourglass that sealed his fate.
By being so full of love that he was willing
to sacrifice his own life, Pinocchio truly
embodied what it means to be human.
Despite her massive impact on everything that
happens to Geppetto, Sebastian, and Pinocchio,
the movie doesn't reveal all that much about
the Wood Sprite.
She first appears as a collection of glowing
orbs that seemingly take interest in Geppetto's
suffering as he chops down a tree while mourning
the death of his son Carlo.
In his narration, Sebastian admits that he
knows very little about what the orbs are
or why they're suddenly flocking to Geppetto's
side.
Later, when Pinocchio visits the afterlife
for the first time, Death tells him that the
Wood Sprite is her sister.
The two of them share a resemblance, with
large wings that appear to have eyeballs sticking
out all over them.
But death gets more screen time and has much
more to say than her sister.
In her final appearance in the film, the Wood
Sprite grants Sebastian his wish and returns
Pinocchio to life.
It seems like she might have known that things
would work out this way all along.
"To save you, he became a real boy, and real
boys don't come back."
However, it's unclear how much she and her
sister communicated and planned during the
events of the film.
Ultimately, the Wood Sprite has little to
say or reveal.
She's simply a mysterious force of nature
that will never be fully understood.